- [Mark] There's the rulers.
(low chime)
The reverb tank.
(metal clanking)
The ebow.
(ominous, high-pitched whine)
- [Tony] A normal instrument.
You're playing it and you're
expecting it to have a sound
that is pleasing.
But with an instrument like this,
the goal is to just produce sounds that,
in this case, are disturbing.
(nightmare machine blares)
(low strings music)
- [Mark] The Apprehension
Engine was an instrument
that creates a variety of really creepy
and some would say horrifying sounds.
My name is Mark Korven.
I'm a film music composer and lately,
I've been focusing on horror movie scores.
(ominous strings)
Two of my biggest hits as far
as horror films are concerned
was from the late nineties,
a film called Cube.
And, most recently, The Witch.
(ominous music)
(tapping)
I originally commissioned
the Apprehension Engine
because I was tired of
the same digital samples,
which resulted in a lot of sameness
of a lot of horror musics.
(ominous music)
So, I was looking for something
more experimental,
more acoustic that would
give me a little bit more
of an original sound.
That's where I contacted my
friend, Tony Duggan-Smith.
- So, Mark called me asking me
to create a crazy instrument
for horror films.
Because I'd never done
anything like that before,
it made me empty out all my
pockets and all my drawers
of any knick-knacks and bits of bobs
I could possibly string together
to make it happen for him.
And this is what came of it.
(off-key string music)
You're dealing with things
that stir primal emotions
and feelings.
And there actually is a skill
set that you have to acquire
in order to get the most out of it.
(off-key string music)
- [Mark] It expresses what
really can't be expressed
any other way.
It's not music in the
traditional sense, at all.
But, let me put this way.
The Apprehension Engine
definitely evokes an emotion,
so I would call it music.
(tapping)
(grinding)